don't mean the pain of  in your car  [Music]  beside the church crowds gramby as soon  as I hit the ground he said the church  how did you get inside the church dead  bodies  slowly sitting down with experiments on  them in there they're doing experiments  on the villagers why just like her on  burning people with these flamethrowers  and they're still moving the bodies  cocoons in the tree did you get I to  Metallica and she's his head she was  half a body and she's still she's still  talking and I saw those opposed boys hey  did you get eyes on the tower compound  that's how we're basing yeah it's below  the ground but there's more than that  down look  what the hell is that  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  what's inside that church what happens  to those people  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Jason he's dead  [Music]  Jase I feel I feel really good Oh  [Applause]  overlord  you